نحن نتواجد الان هنا في منطقه توام غرب
شمال قطاع غزه هذه المنطقه التي كانت
تتواجد بها قوات الاحتلال واليته حيث
انسحب الاحتلال من هذه المنطقه وخلف من
ورائه دمار كبير طال المنازل وطال الشوارع
وطال الطرقات وطال ايضا البنيه التحتيه
لهذه المنطقه بدا الاهالي هنا بالعوده
لهذه المنطقه لتفقد منازلهم لكنهم وجدوا
ان هذه المنطقه اصبحت غير صالحه للسكن
بعدما دمر الاحتلال مئات المنازل ودمر
الشوارع ودمر كل شيء في هذه المنطقه عديت
على البيت لقيت البيت ولا كانه بيت عرفتوش
من كثر الدمار اللي فيه ما عرفتوش ولا
مخليين حاجه صالحه ولا شي يعني ناس جرت زي
ما قال
هاجرنا لقينا البيت ولا في شي يصلح
للسكن صور صور الشعب
الغلبان اليوم زي ما انت شايف اجينا على
منطقه التوام المنطقه اللي ساكنين فيها
قلنا سحب الجيش من المنطقه قلنا بدنا نروح
نشوفها اجينا زي ما انت شايف لقينا الدمار
هائل جدا لا بيوت ولا مساكن ولا مدارس حتى
مساجد مساجد ربنا اللي بروح نصليها ما في
مساجد فش حاجه مخلينا نهائيا والحمد لله
على كل
[موسيقى]
حال كما شاهدتم حجم هذا الدمار وهذا الراب
الذي خلفته قوات الاحتلال بعد انسحابها من
هذه المنطقه انس الشريف الجزيره شمال غزه